[musique]
[applaudissements]
Mais
[musique]
[applaudissements]
je
[musique]
[applaudissements]
il y a des changements mineurs au profil du client
si c'était avant
hommes d'affaires aisés
propriétaires de grandes entreprises
domaines de l'agriculture commerciale et
l'industrie aujourd'hui
ont commencé à apparaître en plus grand nombre
que les anciens cadres supérieurs de l'entreprise
[musique]
Il y a beaucoup de clients sur le marché en ce moment.
qui ne l'ont pas utilisé auparavant.
services d'aviation d'affaires du fait que
service régulier terminé et
abrégé également en Russie donc
de nombreux clients en classe affaires
les compagnies aériennes régulières sont venues aujourd'hui
notre marché
[musique]